the country commonwealth and realms have
a new monarch god save the king
everyone is now looking to him a man
known so well as the prince of wales to
lead them through the grief to a
brighter future
[Applause]
he is a new king but also an old man
[Applause]
[Music]
questions will be asked about whether he
is the right person to deliver the
change needed for the monarchy to
survive
succession is a perilous time for the
crown
the king must rally support not just for
his leadership but for the institution
he is leading
can he do it
the answer lies in his past
[Music]
elizabeth was on the throne
for a lifetime
most people had never known another
monarch people loved her
quite rightly she was
hard not to like
britain 70 odd years on is a very very
different country
in a way the royal family and the queen
have prevented progress being made
because
we've been under the illusion that
britain is still
what it was in 1952 and it isn't
the new king takes the throne at a more
challenging time than the queen people
are more questioning of authority and
resentful of privilege
he must become the ultimate symbol of
national unity while also modernising
the monarchy so it better reflects
today's society
there's no way in which simply by doing
what his mother did
will charles be a success he has to be
different from his mother everybody
thinks that they know him well from
documentaries or from the crown
but in fact you need to go back to the
beginning to the very very different
world that he was born into to get the
secret of what charles is all about
[Music]
it has been announced officially from
buckingham palace during the past hour
that her royal highness the princess
elizabeth duchess of edinburgh was
safely delivered of a prince at 9 14 pm
today
ever since 1948 it's been known that one
day he would be king
but no monarch in british history has
waited so long the world is so different
now from the world that he was born into
that actually he's something of an
enigma
well look charles is a human being like
anybody else and he's subject to
his upbringing his environment like
everybody else is and it was a
rather peculiar upbringing
[Music]
philip and elizabeth were away quite a
lot during his childhood
but i think that he was probably really
quite happy until he went away to school
he goes to team as a boarding school age
nine which is the same boarding school
his father has been to
i think phillip loved
the austere
prep school in bart show that but i
think it was still a rather austere prep
school
when charles a much more sensitive
person went there in the late 1950s
charles by all accounts was a delicate
sort of boy and put into the kind of
ghastly regime at gordon's town in
northern scotland which was not at all
suited to him
and overall we get an impression of a
young boy
not totally at ease with himself
not enjoying a particularly affectionate
relationship with his parents i think it
wasn't universally happy
things are different when he goes to
trinity college cambridge lord butler
master of trinity greets the prince will
major in archaeology and anthropology
the heir to the throne looks like his
mother and walks like his father he did
go to university and there found his
feet found a more artistic sense of
himself which he clearly really sort of
flourished and reveled in
[Music]
and here i am
showing just how adaptable the sports
commentator can be
if you were not in this public position
you'd like to be an actor am i right
well i've often thought about it yes i
do believe i've got a bite i have a bite
i didn't know really whether i could
have been i suppose i might take it this
is most exciting most exciting days it
is great fun i love doing it but whether
i could do it professionally or not is
another matter
i think i got quite a large one here
it's very very large indeed
[Music]
i mean in another life he might have
been an actor but that was never an
option because as the eldest uh son he
was always destined to inherit the
throne i intend to create my son charles
prince of wales today
when he's grown up i will present him to
you at canal charles is named prince of
wales at nine years old but not crowned
until he's 20. university college
aberystwyth where to the relief of the
nation prince charles was given a warm
and very friendly welcome in preparation
for the big event he's plucked from his
cambridge comfort zone and sent off to
aberystwyth university to learn
where under the welsh tuition of mr
edward millward prince charles hopes to
master the intricacies and
pronunciations of welsh
it's a political move aimed at
ingratiating the young prince to the
skeptical welsh
arriving at the wheel of his own car the
prince had come to move into his first
floor room
his next-door neighbor is a welsh
nationalist
jokingly the prince remark i hope he
won't stomp on the wall
in the late 1960s there was a resurgence
of welsh nationalism and saying we're
too dominated by england the welsh
language should be spoken more
the stint in wales may have been a pr
exercise but it paid off in an
unexpected way it showed people this
privileged prince had real empathy there
was quite a lot of strong anti-english
nationalist feeling is it something that
you've come to understand since you've
been in wales i think it is yes you see
i think they feel so strongly about
whales as a nation
and what might happen to it if they
don't
try and preserve the language and the
culture which is very unique and special
to wales and if something is unique and
special i see it's well worth preserving
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the prince of wales is invested at
carnarvon castle in 1969.
it's from this point that he takes on
official responsibilities and starts
carving out a role for himself it's a
process of invention he will do again as
king a modern prince in a medieval
castle kneeling before the queen
who was fulfilling a promise and giving
wales a worthy prince for its own in a
manner set down centuries ago there's a
degree of searching for his own identity
and trying to escape from the
pre-ordained formats
i
charles prince of wales
to become your liege man of life and
limb
and of earthly worship
and it means that where he is now he's
he's come to that through a process of
striving
what happens after after trinity and
finishing with archaeology and
anthropology a certain time in the
services would be a very good idea
i think it gives one a
very useful
experience for useful experience of
responsibility and discipline
i think
is that the most important thing is the
actual trust that's put in you
to deal with other people
and the feeling that they can perhaps
put their trust in you as well
historically the relationship between
military and the monarchy has always
been
really close i mean monarchs used to
literally lead their armies into battle
i don't think that that's going to be a
fundamental sort of part of charles's
identity as a monarch i think it's much
more likely to be the sort of softer
qualities that will perhaps come to the
fore
growing up during the formality and
decorum of the 1950s and 60s charles
seemed old-fashioned a boy that does
what he's told
for somebody with such a senior role
there's remarkably little ability to
choose your own destiny until perhaps
he's in his late 20s and 30s
the job description for a prince of
wales is pretty non-existent and there's
never been a prince of wales who was
waiting in that role for such a long
time he's had to sort of find his
passions find his authority and find his
purpose
he's a king with a lifetime's experience
of being a prince can he turn that to
his advantage
[Music]
university degree complete
stint in the navy over charles finally
breaks free from the shackles of his
strict upbringing and has some fun
[Music]
now in his late twenties the palace and
press suggest the fun stops and pressure
the prince to settle down
charles was clearly as heir to the
throne charged with finding a young
bride without a past who would provide
him with an heir and although you know
it was in the 1980s or the late 1970s
actually that particular responsibility
of an air is age-old
[Music]
she saw it as a love match as marrying
her prince
what was your instant impression both of
you
what are you talking about ladies and
gentlemen i remember thinking what a
very jolly and amusing and
attractive 16 year old she was
and i mean great fun
and fancy and full of life and
everything
and um
i didn't know what you thought of me
pretty amazing
he saw it as about doing his duty and i
suppose in love
of course
whatever in love means
your own interpretation obviously it
means two very happy people
once again congratulations well from us
congratulations
you know so many people over the years
have thought i think that
he went into that marriage just so that
he
could have the sun in the air and but he
never loved her never intended
to for the further marriage to work was
always in love with camilla i don't buy
that at all
i think he went into that marriage
with all the best intentions but it
didn't work
they were not completely compatible
diana overshadowed him they became
rivals the public were always much more
interested in the private life of the
prince of wales and not his public life
and as she approached our camera on the
first floor the worst moment seemed to
be negotiating the stairs with her long
skirt
that accomplished she smiled broadly
his public life really was pretty
pretty boring in a way for the media
princess diana chose a cream light wool
coat dress tonight the princess revealed
the dress she'd chosen for the gala
evening at la scala the problem for the
princess was whether her handbag or a
hand could best keep her bolero style
hat in place the attention was all on
diana and not on charles
so this actually presented problems
within the marriage
the crowds were gathered in the
forecourt before dawn to see the
princess for the first time there was a
misalignment of expectation and their
patience was rewarded as she rode in an
open car in a slow motorcade and charles
also i mean if we reflect back on the
kind of upbringing he had
he was not very demonstrative he found
he had never experienced
warm loving relationships from his
parents
diana you know had an instinctive need
to be loved in many ways the odds were
stacked against them and that of course
is before the third party in the
marriage
is factored in
it is announced from buckingham palace
that with regret the prince and princess
of wales have decided to separate the
result of the marriage failing
was another huge nail in charles's
popularity coffin
the public blamed him for the breakdown
of that marriage
i was there during a very difficult time
of his last marriage it was
extraordinarily painful period for
them both and everybody around them and
for the children
he's a very very resilient person
and when you're going through something
as difficult as that
you know many of us have but none of us
have gone through the process of having
your private life picked apart in the
public domain you know day by day in
such
excruciating detail
the netflix series the crown
i think did huge damage to charles and
his reputation
because it painted a very black picture
of him
observing how a younger generation who
literally weren't alive when diana was
alive
how are viscerally against charles on
account of his relationship diana having
watched the crown it wasn't
factual
it was loosely based on facts but it was
not factual it was not accurate
and it i thought was very unfair to him
the story ultimately is about
three in a marriage
diana being pursued this tragic heroine
by the paparazzi and dying a tragic
death as a woman in her prime about to
find happiness in her personal life
leaving two boys
and that's the narrative that charles
now has to take forward
william and harry are just children when
their mother dies
her absence leads to a much closer
relationship with their father something
the royal family is keen to promote
seeing the three together charles looks
like a natural hands-on dad
he's done an amazing job and without
telling us what we should be doing or
the direction that we should go in he's
just let us learn
from from from the nature of the job and
learn from him learn from mummy
[Music]
there are so many things i admire about
my father his work ethic his passions
all that sort of side of things are
absolutely
crucial
um to to how he's been such successful
prince of wales and an amazing father
[Music]
i think it's just really difficult in a
family when there's so much pressure
charles has tried very hard to be a good
father to those boys
us and and the relationship with william
seems to be very much in sync
with harry it's a work in progress
what have we done
wrong growing up in the spotlight
himself charles tries to prepare his
sons for the same
he knows what it's like to have a life
exposed to public scrutiny
we know a lot about him
um we know rather more than he would
like us to know about him his private
life was very much there for
for
you know for the vultures to pick at
in the 1980s and 90s
but he's come through that people are
familiar with him with his pluses and
minuses and he won't be seen as a
breath of fresh air happy birthday but
familiarity might not be a problem for
the king's popularity
yes he makes mistakes just like everyone
else
that openness was missing with the queen
it could be his key to becoming a modern
monarch
what the monarchy is meant to do is
perhaps
you know reflect the nation back onto
itself where'd you find these terrible
things
how am i feeling
i'm not sure it's rather like
indigestion many happy returns are not
quite the same things you get older
does he now as king
command that just extra kind of magic
and mystique that draws people
around the world to him
charles is right for his period in
history
it would be quite wrong to put somebody
who was as
mysterious as the queen
on the throne today
his success will ultimately depend on
what the public want from their monarch
magic
or realism
[Music]
some people have accused you of meddling
really
you don't say
he might have been shy growing up but
charles did find his voice as prince of
wales giving personal opinions on
controversial subjects
now he's king will he go quiet and
should he
will he be a meddling king
i think he will have some pretty robust
conversations with his prime ministers
but i always wonder what medley is i
mean i always thought it was motivating
you see i don't see it as meddling i see
it it's caring
not a meddling prince but a caring king
if it's meddling to worry about the
inner cities as i did 40 years ago what
was happening or not happening there
the conditions in which people were
living if that's meddling i'm very proud
of it he understands the importance of
our constitution
unwritten though it be and
recognises why the monarchy has been
successful all these years why his
mother was so successful
i think he will
hold his tongue
i do realize that it is a separate
exercise being sovereign
it's of course
uh you know i understand entirely how
that should operate
surely a head of state should have a
view should speak out and so i think
there's a real challenge now that is a
mute head of state somebody whose
opinions we know not of
is that really an asset and charles is
going to have to decide whether to lean
into that silent role of a
constitutional monarch or take a risk
and speak out a bit more
if the king does speak out he'll tread
carefully remembering the criticism over
his black spider memos
[Music]
charles when he was prince of wales
behaved in a way that i think was quite
inappropriate by writing to government
ministers in what's called black spider
letters
[Music]
which he was arguing for particular
government policies
the memos petitioned ministers on a
range of subjects close to charles's
heart from the iraq war to the badger
cull
yes he would write letters and raise
things and occasionally i read that i
founded a problem but i never did
because it was always perfectly decently
expressed and it was private between the
two of us except when someone else would
talk about it did you think he had the
role to give ministers instructions
absolutely not
did he feel that
it was totally within his rights to
express a view and to share some
thoughts
and to pass something onto ministers
rather than just what they were
receiving from civil servants yes
and i would say i would say why not but
it was almost always and i can't think
of a an exception to this
sensible and
interesting and based on his experiences
with people i remember vividly myself
the ministers were actually very
interested to hear from the prince of
wales there's a growing sense that
actually if you have a position of head
of state should you not have opinions on
certain things
being the prince of wales
through all those years i mean it's
incredibly difficult to find the right
modus operandi for yourself and you know
i think he he did it really and that's
that's why
i think we can be confident about him as
as a king
in writing the black spider memos
charles is accused of crossing a line
into political territory
but not all his passions are as
controversial
the charity he set up to improve the
lives of young people though originally
opposed by government ministers is now
universally considered a success
the prince's trust started when the then
prince of wales left the navy in 1976
and he was given seven and a half
thousand pounds severance pay he put
that into finding a trust and it began
small
the prince's trust was there to try and
reach
the parts of society that others were
not reaching
what i hope we've been able to do is to
help
some people's
dreams to come true lots of people told
him it wouldn't work
with only a little persuasion he tried
his hand as a dj
mixing and scratching before an audience
of young homeless people in south london
the princess trust is a genuine project
and it's transformed i would say
millions of people's lives
dig that crazy rhythm
i don't think he's been big enough i
told him too i don't think he's been
bold enough
what it's done which is not
insignificant
is to empower young people
i want to say empowering young people
but also transforming institutions
he's bristling with ideas about
harnessing talent and about maximizing
the potential of young people
he loved getting kids into the theater
and
watching shakespeare from her from a
young age when i was a teenager trying
to figure out what i was going to do
with my life
acting the theater storytelling was an
aspiration but there was no real path
for me
the prince's trust came along
as a means of helping me fund going to
join the national youth music theatre
being part of that production led to me
going to drama school
and and led to the career i have now
his view is
that if you give opportunity if you give
a sense of purpose a sense of belonging
it's a win-win we all flourish
it's not as though
i'm taking the cake from you
the cakes just got bigger
i think without the prince's trust
coming along
i just don't know that a i would have
pursued it i don't also think that i
would have
been given that encouragement that comes
from
someone somewhere going we think you are
worthy of support
i think what motivates the king is a
real desire
to make life better for people
would you notice improvements
in the area
and to make society better to make
community better
the prince's trust achieved that but
it's not the biggest cause charles has
united people behind
he spent his adult life pushing an issue
people didn't care about up the agenda
it's now the issue the world cares about
[Music]
over the next 60 years if we go on as we
are doing
something like a third
of all the forms of life at present
living on this planet may be extinct
one of the unusual things about being
prince of wales never mind king is the
extent to which you don't apply for that
job you're there and it's not a thing
that you can plan for or you find
yourself in it
it struck me that from a very early age
when he found himself there he decided
he was going to use that position for
the very best possible good for the wild
that he could
it was neither popular nor mainstream
but charles was resolute about
protecting the environment
it became the purpose he'd been
searching for as prince of wales
straight afterwards the prince displayed
his concern for his tree
[Music]
early on he settled on these ecological
subjects as being the things that really
were the ones that needed the most
attention
i think on the environment
he felt so passionately about it he felt
that he couldn't be silenced he was
talking about climate change before
climate change was remotely fashionable
there's no doubt that on the environment
charles has authenticity and he does
have credibility
as a as an international leader
you know literally the only
establishment figure in the 70s 80s and
90s who was consistently championing all
of this but i think also he was on a
trajectory where increasingly people
were beginning to understand and believe
that actually what he was saying was
right the key is that there is much
greater opportunity in doing these
things
in a better greener more sustainable way
all the things that have been rubbished
for so long
from his point of view it was more that
he understood that we were a part of
nature that you could not separate man
out from nature and he thinks that our
undoing was basically
that separation
[Music]
he was pulling together people from
major corporations from different parts
of the global uh system to come together
to think about you know what can we
actually do
because up until the point he was doing
that work it was either a group of
scientists or a group of campaigners or
a group of somebody else trying to do
some kind of a solution he realized that
until you put all these together that's
when you get the breakthroughs
[Music]
he was involved
not just opening cop
but also in a lot of the meetings before
and after it around the side i mean he
sort of set up almost a court there and
he you know there was a lot of soft
power that he was using and utilizing
as support for the environment grew so
did charles's ability to speak on it
without criticism as king the
environment is going to be absolutely
critically important for a lot of what
he does
and i think that the thing is is that in
a way it's become easier for him because
partly because he's helped make it
mainstream
and now it is mainstream it's not so
politically controversial the green
monarch is that something that he you
know he might decide to be
he's gonna have to really live that out
and it's no good just speaking out about
it if he's then flying around the world
on jets and so on
[Music]
there's going to be immediately
questions about how sustainable is it to
live the life of a british monarch
[Music]
what about the wealth what about the
policies what about the travel
how the king adapts his own life and
land will be significant the monarchy is
there to set an example and show it too
is prepared to make sacrifices but you
know that's in a way i think his best
chance
of being seen as relevant rather than a
relic of a bygone age
if he does embrace the green monarch it
could place the royal family front and
center in tackling one of the biggest
issues of the day
transforming the future monarchy into
something that is not just relevant but
critical
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the queen's platinum jubilee marked her
70-year reign
the celebrations presented the perfect
opportunity to showcase the future of
the monarchy
charles trained by the queen completing
his king's apprenticeship
william trained by charles starting his
your majesty
mommy
[Applause]
you've been with us in our difficult
times
and you bring us together to celebrate
moments of pride
joy
and happiness
charles led tributes to his mother but
he also stood in for her showing the
british public he was already performing
the role of sovereign
there has for a long time been a de
facto regency
with charles doing many of the duties so
i think that we're used to charles
really as as the co-head of state
the transition has now ended and the
king rules alone
head of an unsettled state
he comes to the throne at a time
when we've had disunity in our country
we've gone through the contentiousness
of brexit
when there have been wars in europe
when people have questioned the role of
the crown in some of the countries where
the you know where there are realms
what's the new role of the commonwealth
where
multi-racial britain has got to work
[Applause]
a head of state there by virtue of birth
a white privileged family
ruling over a multicultural multi-ethnic
society
how is that sustainable in in the modern
world so how does a white man with the
with with the greatest of entitlements
become the figurehead for a
multicultural society
with empathy
with compassion
with a good ear
the parade will now
march past in quick time and pay final
compliments to the monarchy
he used that advice in barbados when the
commonwealth nation replaced the queen
as head of state from this day and
forever
declare barbados a parliamentary
republic
[Applause]
i was so deeply touched that you should
have
invited me to return to barbados
when we both go to barbados as it
becomes a republic from the darkest days
of our past and he talks about the the
atrocities
under the enslavement of
my descendants
and the appalling atrocity of slavery
which forever stains our history
and we have to acknowledge it
own it
but start to put things right
what the the prince then
and that the king now will try and do
is to take the nation
into the 21st century
have these uncomfortable conversations
because
it's what a leader should do
[Music]
it wouldn't be obvious that the
commonwealth would still be existing in
the mid 21st century and that's a
testament to the queen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
one thing that charles will have to do
is really work at that to ensure that
that continues
[Music]
i think the commonwealth will keep
together
but countries in the caribbean and
africa will want to become more we want
to become republics
and i think you have to accept that
people want to break the yolk
of the colonial power it's likely to be
an inevitable process for most of those
countries that retain uh links to the
british crown particularly in the
caribbean i don't think that will be
seen as particularly a judgment on
charles
and i don't think it would necessarily
mean that you know britain is then going
to be ultimately uh
set to get rid of the monarchy
but actually if it doesn't fundamentally
address
as much as it can
uh its place
in the 21st century
then
it looks like a relic of the past and
it's a white relic of the past and
that's really problematic
it is the challenge of keeping the
monarchy relevant the charles will face
again and again both abroad and at home
that majority of the public i think
they're very happy with the molecule
prepared to have a monarchy but what
they don't want is a monarchy we've got
they don't want all the hangers on who
are they all
the royal family is being slimmed down
so the public's gaze is focused on the
sovereign the air and their partners
his plan
is to slim down the monarchy because the
one bug bear that the media pick up on
year after year is the cost
charles is acutely aware of you know
every year that becomes a bit of an
embarrassment during the 1990s in the
sort of latest iteration of the royal
family it became a real liability as the
marriages of the queen's children fell
apart even in the latter part of the
queen's reign with you know prince harry
deciding he wants to step away from
royal duties and prince andrew you have
a sense that the royal family can become
more trouble than they're worth
it's a shame that megan and harry chose
not to to stay here
they were never going to be
the senior figures which might have
actually been one of the problems it is
difficult
this thing of being the second child of
a monarch
it makes much more sense which is i
think charles's vision to have
him and camilla and then
william and kate as the core of the
monarchy
camilla as queen consort will play a key
and visible role supporting the king
it's an extraordinary transformation
from the unpopular third person in
charles and diana's marriage to a
well-respected royal
[Music]
until she married the prince of wales
she was hidden from view so nobody knew
her nobody even heard her speak
when she then married the prince of
wales
she was out and about
people met her they realized that
actually she wasn't this gustly woman
this rottweiler she was actually very
nice
she has
become sort of one of the more
interesting members of the royal family
taking up interesting causes
domestic violence the importance of
childhood reading the importance of live
theater during the pandemic and sort of
the need to speak up for the creative
industries it's just doing so much for
so many young people and old people
as a silver spot myself i assume
she's done a tremendously important role
visible and out there when necessary
low-key and supportive
making people laugh in our own
inimitable way in small groups
[Music]
she seems very open very relaxed
[Music]
and that might be
sort of actually the model that the
monarchy will take in the future
the new king and queen will certainly be
more informal figureheads but they will
have to judge the public mood before
deciding how much further they go in
modernising the monarchy
there is no doubt that the death of the
queen marks the end
of a long chapter in monarchical history
and the the last of a certain type of
monarch
the country's changing the world is
changing the way the monarchy
interacts and and places itself as an
institution
perhaps needs to change
maybe it's his role in delivering that
change so then it's in a good shape
for william to take over
some time ahead he has to show
leadership and it's going to be rocky
because there are forces out there
that would like him to maintain the
status quo
and he wants a society that's
comfortable with his past and and
confident about his future
uh i hope he can pull it off yes a new
king but also an old man and that in
many ways is going to be the challenge
now for the new king to command the
affection
or anything like the affection that his
mother had and of course the sustained
support of the people
what we've had in this country for 1200
years is a monarchy i think charles will
be very able monarch but i think it only
survives if he has a relationship with
us and we feel we have a relationship
with him
[Music]
and i think he's incredibly well
preserved and he's been as it were
rehearsing for decades
now in this time of national grief he's
going to help bring us together
and i say god save the king
[Music]
you